I was born youngest of 8 and miR across
the Narrow Sea so my father gave me over
to the red temple in their wisdom they
decided to make me a priest instead of a
warrior or a temple prostitute like
other children it was not the path I
would have chosen sure I prayed the
prayers and I spoke the spells but I
also led raids on the kitchens and from
time to time they found girls in my bed
such wicked girls I never knew how they
got there then again I did have a gift
for tongues and when I gazed into the
flames well from time to time I saw
things even so I was more bother than I
was worth when a high priest for saw
Roberts ascension he sent me to turn the
storm Lord to the Lord of Light when
Robert seized his crown we take all of
Westeros from the seven in a single
stroke perhaps they thought Robert would
listen to a kindred spirit
or perhaps celibacy had addled the high
priests brain I didn't know and didn't
care I was free I did my duty as I saw
it drinking and whoring and waving my
sword around the any cards Robert cared
about anyway years passed Robert became
king I became a joke we both became fat
I even won some glory and Greyjoy's
rebellion first through the breach and
all that
it's amazing what boldness of HO bladder
can inspire but Robert has stopped
listening to my sermons a long time ago
even if I still bother to give them then
came Robert's death and the war I'm not
speaking of those brats squabbling over
the world's pointiest chair powers long
asleep awaking and moving through the
land I've seen them in my flames [ __ ]
I've seen them with my own two eyes the
Lord of Light is real and if he's real
then all of it is real man once again
faces the war for the dawn which has
been waged since time began on one side
is the Lord of Light the heart of fire
the god of flame and shadow against him
stands the great other whose name may
not be spoken the Lord of Darkness the
soul of ice the God of night meant to
tear us according to prophecy our
champion will be reborn to wake dragons
from stone and reforge the great sword
Lightbringer that defeated the darkness
those thousands of years ago if the old
tales are true a terrible weapon forged
with the lifeblood of a loving wife's
heart part of me thinks man was well rid
of it but great power requires great
sacrifice that much at least the Lord of
Light is Clara
I sound like a dried-out old woman I
know but is our former hand like to say
winter is coming
when the cold winds rise all men no
matter their faith or lack of it huddled
beside my night fires and I pray the
prayers and speak the spells and beseech
the Lord of Light to bring back the door
so far so good but reprobate as I am I
can't help but wonder what will happen
if one day our Lord does not answer
imagine a night that goes on forever so
dark and full of terrors I think I need
another drink